durant la deuxième quinzaine de juillet
le programme apollo 11 va se dérouler
quel est ce projet est bien la nasa a
l'intention est l'ambition d'envoyer un
homme un équipage directement sur la
lune comment se déroulera cette
opération eh bien il suffit de se
tourner vers ce schéma symbolique assez
fantaisiste il faut bien le reconnaître
qu'ils représentent d'une part la terre
et d'autre part la lune dans un premier
temps le satellite quittera le cap
kennedy aux états unis et après une
trajectoire déterminé par les lois de la
mécanique céleste à partir de l'ongle du
point kennedy qui se trouve dans le la
dans l'ouest des états unis
ce satellite dirigera progressivement
selon une trajectoire parfaitement
définis vers la lune et à ce moment là
il se placera sur une orbite circulaire
d'attentes autour de la lune jusqu'à
présent les phases d'exploration lunaire
était bien classés puisque le satellite
partant de la paire arrivant sur la lune
se placer uniquement sur une orbite
d'attentes mais le projet cette fois ci
est beaucoup plus ambitieux puisque les
américains ont projeté en définitive que
à partir du satellite sur sa position
d'orbites lunaire détachera un élément
qu'on qui le constituent qu on appelle
le mobile d'une haie et dont la mission
est de venir se poser aussi délicatement
que possible à sur la surface même de la
lune nous voici donc sur la surface
lunaire directement puisque le mobile
devient de se poser et à bord de ce
module une caméra cette caméra des
livres d ivoire d images noir et blanc
et effectuera donc un certain nombre de
prises de vues de son environnement
local et les images de ce mobile lunaire
seront transmis par l'intermédiaire d'un
émetteur se situant à bord du mobile
lunaire vers la vers le satellite c'est
à dire vers la cellule apollo qui
recevra ses émissions et par
l'intermédiaire d'un second d'un autre
émetteur les retransmettra en direction
de la terre ce schéma peut faire
illusion en effet il semble que les
trajets à effet qu'à faire effectuer au
dimanche 3 1 puisqu'il conviendrait
d'aller du mobile lunaire à la cellule à
satellite placé sur orbite et enfin du
satellite vers la terre et bien en fait
la toute la complication de
l'électronique a joué pour ses
transmissions
en effet les signaux qui sont émis par
cette caméra transmis vers le module
vers le satellite sur orbite son côté
d'une certaine façon pourquoi
et bien c'est parce que on sait que pour
transmettre une quantité d'informations
il faut disposer d'une certaine largeur
de bande
or les largeurs de bande se paye très
cher au point de vue d'électronique des
cons et dans l'espace il a donc fallu
trouver des systèmes très astucieux pour
condenser ces informations et si on
transmettait directement ces
informations vers la terre on ne
pourrait les recevoir sur un téléviseur
commercial en effet si l'on a compliqué
la transmission au départ cela signifie
également qu'il faudrait compliqué les
récepteurs d'une façon exagérée et on
obtiendrait ainsi des prix de revient
commerciaux absolument incompatible avec
la diffusion des téléviseurs dans les
circuits commerciaux
par conséquent première transformation à
bord de la cellule sur orbite
ensuite une deuxième transformation est
nécessaire un deuxième codage
électronique extrêmement compliqué
également doit intervenir puisque les
caméras qui sont à bord du vaisseau
spatial sur orbite autour de la lune
diffuse des images en couleur
ces images en couleurs vont donc être
reçu mais d'abord être mélangés c'est
cela signifie qu'il y aura un
transcodage en quelque sorte à bord de
cette cellule est que l'ensemble du ce
programme de ce mini programmes ainsi
constitué aboutira via une liaison
extrêmement longues difficiles à faire
et qui nécessite bien entendu ici encore
toutes les ressources de l'électronique
pour obtenir des images de qualité et
c'est ainsi que cette image va enfin
parvenir aux stations terriennes de
houston et du cap kennedy nous disposons
donc maintenant des images qui
parviennent delà du satellite aux états
unis eh bien ces images sont délivrés
dans le système américain c'est à dire
525 ligne et en ce qui concerne les
transmissions couleurs en ntsc
or ces images ne sont utilisables
directement que par les réseaux de
l'amérique du nord du canada de certains
pays d'amérique latine et du japon les
autres réseaux de télévision ne peuvent
pas utiliser ces images parce que pour
la plupart ils utilisent
normes différentes et ses normes et
généralement le 500e 625 ligne et le
système coups de couleurs et soit le pal
soit le ceca par conséquent les images
vont donc être reçus en ce qui concerne
les pays de l'union européenne de
radiodiffusion
c'est à dire les pays de l'europe
occidentale et en ce qui concerne les
pays de des pays à économie socialiste
c'est-à-dire géré par l'organisation
internationale de radio de télévision
louis berthet ces images vont donc être
reçu à londres via un satellite
transmission bien classique que les
téléspectateurs connaissent maintenant
cette station terrienne de gouny vit en
angleterre va donc procéder à la
distribution pour le réseau européen
et pour les réseaux des pays socialistes
à une distribution dans un système à 625
ligne codée au point de vue de la
couleur en salle à paris pour utiliser
ses émissions sur nos propres antennes
nous aurons donc un transcodage de pales
en ccam pour diffusion sur la deuxième
chaîne et une autre un autre transcodage
pour passer du 520 du 625 ligne pâle au
819 ligne noir et blanc pour la
diffusion sur la première chaîne
un télé classement d'imagés de
modulation a donc nécessité la mise en
place à houston d'un staff ou d'un
groupe de travail qui est chargé
d'assurer la coordination de la
distribution des images la coordination
des circuits de son la coordination des
circuits téléphone vers les différents
pays utilisateurs
ce groupe international se divise en
plusieurs sections et notamment en ce
qui concerne les pays de l'union
européenne de radiodiffusion
c'est un ingénieur de l'office de
radiodiffusion télévision française un
ingénieur en chef monsieur jacques
bouillon qui s'est rendu sur place qui a
eu comme mission d'assurer d'une part le
secrétariat général de toutes ces
opérations car certes il existe une
phase administrative est également il
est chargé de la coordination de tous
les moyens techniques mises en oeuvre
pour les besoins de l'union européenne
de radio j
notre camarade ingénieurs monsieur
geoffroy viens de vous dire combien
l'opération son plan technique était
compliquée sur le plan journalistique
je dois dire qu'elle n'est pas plus en
effet si nous voyons la carte des
opérations nous apercevons que le point
principal d'intérêt d'abord et à houston
au texas et laquelle centre de contrôle
de la nasa
c'est là aussi que sont installés toutes
les télévisions américaines et mondiales
mais nous pour nous il s'agit de donner
aux téléspectateurs français un
programme est un programme
c'est ce que peut donner la nasa en
images et en sons et puis c'est aussi
quelque chose de plus c'est ce qui
permet de comprendre ce que donne la
nasa c'est pour ça que l'opération est
complexe à nasa à houston la nasa va
d'abord donné une image elle va la
donner au réseau américain
mais nous ne pouvons pas utiliser
directement l'image des réseaux
américains parce qu ainsi que vous le
savez tous les quarts d'heure dans un
programme américain même s'il s'agit de
montrer des images de la lune on injecte
des séquences publicitaires séquence
publicitaire américaine nous ne pouvons
pas nous les diffuser en europe c'est
vrai non seulement pour nous français
mais pour tous les pays de l' eurovision
nous sommes donc obligés déjà à partir
de cette image en direct et sur le champ
de fabriquer une image nouvelle qui soit
pour nous consommables c'est pour ça que
l'eurovision de genève a envoyé à
houston va envoyer à houston un groupe
de travail international avec des
français des italiens des allemands des
anglais tu iras et ce groupe de travail
ne fabriquera l'image que vous verrez
l'image en direct j'entends que vous
verrez sur le plan du son les choses
sont encore plus compliquées
en effet la nasa met à la disposition
des utilisateurs de son le dialogue
entre les cosmonautes et la terre c'est
le son spatial et puis un commentaire
que la nasa y ajoute pour permettre la
compréhension de ce dialogue parce que
vous savez que très souvent les choses
sont pratiquement en code et enfin nous
naturellement nous envoyons à houston
jax albert qui comme à chaque occasion à
grandes occasions spéciales
suivra pour nous les choses en direct de
là bas nous recevrons donc déjà 300 c
sans nous les amenons toujours par
satellite et aussi en secours par câble
sous marin
d'où les anneaux jusqu'à paris mais il
faut encore que ils parviennent jusqu'à
vous téléspectateurs il faut aussi
prévoir
le cas où il aurait eu une panne de son
nous savons que cela se produit nous
savons par expérience qu'il est plus
délicat de transporter le son à travers
ses grands espaces que de transporter
l'image
nous sommes donc obligés de prévoir à
paris quelque chose de plus c'est pour
ça que michel ans frôlent et jean pierre
chapel seront là non seulement vous
fournir des explications
non seulement pour interviewer les
spécialistes qui eux seront à paris et à
houston mais aussi éventuellement en cas
d'ennuis pour suppléer à une défaillance
de la des transmissions et pour se
substituer à jax albert alors au total
l'opération est complexe
il n'empêche qu'elle sera au fond
pratiquement permanente et c'est ainsi
que par exemple le 21 juillet si tout va
bien à 6h30 du matin ce qui sera une
heure particulièrement matinale pour la
télévision française je crois d'ailleurs
pratiquement sans précédent nous
pourrons nous espérons pouvoir vous
montrer en direct en couleurs et avec
tous ces sons avec toutes ces
collaborations les premiers pas de
l'homme sur la lune